hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast data collection as
environmental enrichment automated
behavioral measurement and voluntary
homepage operates tasks and presented by
Jamie alloy Dallaire postdoctoral
researcher in the department of
comparative medicine at Stanford
University I am Alexis Corrales of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's labret is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your question into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have Charles seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain your credits please joining me
and welcome Jamie alloy Dallaire I will
now turn the presentation over to him
Thank You Alexis and hi to everyone
watching this presentation my
presentation is about collecting
experimental data from research animals
directly in their phone cages by using
automated versions of operative tests
that they get to engage with on a
voluntary basis I'm going to focus on
why and how we should integrate these
types of tests into biomedical research
especially and particularly in mice
because of how widely used the species
is so here's a quick outline of how this
presentation will unfold I'm going to
start off by telling you why I think you
should care which is the animal models
in biomedical research currently you're
really producing results that carryover
it
patience as readily as we'd like them to
and hoping to convince you that part of
the solution to make these results more
applicable to humans is to treat
research animals more like we treat
human patients and among other things
that means making their well-being a top
priority
I hope to show you that in general this
is beneficial not just for the animals
but for the quality of the science
itself I'll lend out the detail on the
role and potential benefits of one very
specific aspect of treating animals like
humans which is collecting data from
them voluntarily in their own cages
instead of forcing them to participate
in standard hand run tests that they
might find aversive in various ways so
here's here's the big problem that we're
trying to deal with out of all the
experimental drugs that are tested in
human clinical trials only 11% of them
succeed in making it to market
one reason for 89% of them failing is
that sometimes there's unexpected side
effects but most of the time it's
because they just don't work and that's
pretty mind-blowing because all of these
drugs were tested in animals and they
worked that's why they ended up being
tested in humans and the ethical
consequences of this are pretty
horrifying because it means that too
many animals are being used in
experiments that usually induce some
sort of suffering and then there's not
enough benefit coming back in the form
of defective treatments being developed
for human patients who are also poor
suffering so what's my on why don't
these treatments work in the in the
humans if they worked in the animals I
think a big part of that reason is that
preclinical research on animals is often
done very differently from clinical
research on human patients this includes
how the experiments are analyzed and
designed and it includes how the human
and animal patients are treated
throughout the course of the experiment
and how the outcomes of the experiments
are measured to put it more bluntly I
think it's often the case the human and
the animal researchers are using
different goal posts are different ways
of determining whether a drug works or
not and so they're not surprising that
they sometimes get different answers and
these are issues that we've explored in
a review paper that we published last
year in the journal lab animal and of
course we're not the only ones there are
many many
other authors who discuss these issues
along with some potential solutions and
I'm just showing you a very small
selection of these papers here now in
this presentation I'm going to focus
primarily on the issue of trying to
treat animals humanely in the same way
that we trade treat human patients and
I'll focus on how this can affect the
quality of the science so let's start
with a few examples here's some data
from an experiment on self
administration of analgesic drugs or
painkillers in mice female mice were
subjected to an experimental surgery and
then they were allowed to self-medicate
to relieve their own pain they had two
bottles in their own cage one of them
containing water and the other one
containing ibuprofen an ibuprofen and
eight ibuprofen intake increased over
the two weeks following surgery in the
operated mice which is exactly what
you'd expect if they're in pain and if
the ibuprofen is relieving that thing
effectively but here's the crucial twist
the mice were housed in one of four
different conditions they were either
housed in groups of three or by
themselves and they were either house in
barren cages that contained only wood
chip bedding the bottom of the cage or
they were housed in environmentally
enriched cages that also contains
material to build a nest and some wooden
chewing sticks and it turned out that
the mice consumed less of the analgesic
if they were housing groups and if they
were housed in enriched cages so what
this shows is that the social and
physical environment of these mice
affected how severe their pain was and
how much pain relief they felt that they
needed I'll show you another example to
show that this isn't just something
that's going on in their heads here's an
example where the housing environment
actually has very real tangible physical
consequences on health here hamsters
were housed either alone or with one of
their siblings and they were given a
small wound on their backs using a punch
biopsy and starting on the day after the
wound was inflicted one half of the
hamsters who were pair housed and one
half of the single housed hamsters were
restrained in a small tube and they were
held there for two hours every day this
is called the chronic restraint stress
procedure and all of the hamsters in all
the conditions the wounds healed over
time but there was one group that
more slowly than the others and that's
the announcers who were subjected to the
daily restraints that stress and who had
who were housed by themselves and the
authors actually did a separate
experiment to work out the mechanisms
behind this they got another group of
hamsters and they have them either alone
or in pairs and they measured how much
cortisol these animals produced when
they were restrained in tube cortisol is
a hormone that is secreted in stressful
situations and so correspondingly being
restrained in two big fast temporary
spikes in cortisol production but these
spikes only happened in the socially
isolated animals so being housed with
the social partner actually seems to
have been enough to buffer the animals
against the physiological consequences
of that restraint stress and the infant
negative impacts of it on healing here's
one more example of how housing quality
can have dramatic impacts on animal
health this research was done on sprog
dolly rats who are enough reggienet
extracted stock of rats that are often
used in breast cancer research because
they actually spontaneously develop
mammary tumors in this experiment the
rats were housed either groups of five
in a large cage or alone in small cages
and when they were 15 months of age they
were checked for tumors and the rats
work out the nice elation had developed
a low a larger total tumor burden and
they had more malignant tumors than a
group has rats
two months before this tumor check the
researchers had actually assessed the
physiological stress response of each
rat by restraining them just like the
hamsters except they only tested it once
and just like in the hamsters the
isolated rats had more severe stress
responses than the group housed rats and
the researchers were actually able to
show that the magnitude of the stress
response was what predicted development
of tumors a few months after that test
so this shows again one more time that
social contact which is good for welfare
in a social species also helps protect
the animals from environmental stressors
and from the effects of these stressors
have on health so there's a direct
parallel to this rat research in humans
this is data from
paper where researchers tracked almost
3,000 women who had breast cancer and
they asked these women about their
social networks their social connections
how many relatives do you have how many
friends do you participate in community
or church groups and based on all of
these responses they classified the
women on a spectrum from being either
socially integrated or being socially
isolated or somewhere in between and the
women were rated as socially isolated
actually died of their cancers rates
twice as high as the socially integrated
women women said they had no friends
were four times as likely to die of
their cancer it was similar effects for
whether or not they had close relatives
so just as in the rodents we see that
there's tremendous importance of social
support in determining health outcomes
there's another important thing to note
about this study if you look at the
numbers below each column and equals
that's the number of women in each of
these categories you can see that there
weren't that many women in the socially
isolated highest risk group they were
less than 10% of the entire sample and
far larger numbers of women were well
socially integrated and so that shows
one way in which treating animals
humanely isn't just about improving
their welfare and it's not even just
about improving the health it's really
also about making them more like the
humans that they're being used as a
models of because most human patients
can count on some measure of support
from their loved ones and to model this
as faithfully as possible in rodents the
right approach is probably also to
usually allow them to have some large
social contact and social social support
and experience and there's another way
in which worrying about the welfare of
research animals is also really about
making sure that they're good models of
human patients so I just showed you
several examples where environmental
enrichment given to lab rodents improve
their health outcomes
these are enrichment like social
companionship or nesting material but we
can ask ourselves what it is exactly
about these enrichments that does this
or what do these enrichments do for the
animals welfare well being part of what
they do is that they let the animals
control their environments with all
their environments in a way that depth
on forests
in the environment social companions for
example provides support that buffers
against stressors like the restraint
stress procedure that was in both by
experimenters and that's also in a way
what nesting material does if you think
about how mice live in a lab the ambient
temperatures at which we have mice are
actually several degrees below their
thermal neutral zone and what that means
is that if they don't have a nesting
material they're chronically cold
stressed in these environments but with
nesting material they can use their
behavior to create a little micro
environment around themselves a nest
which retains their body heat and keeps
them comfortable and when you think
about it that's exactly what we do as
humans do I'm sitting in this office
right now and the thermostat is set
several degrees below my thermo neutral
zone and I'm fine because I put on
clothing this morning I use my behavior
to create a nice little snug micro
environment that I carry around with me
and so the humans and mice are both made
to control their environments using
their behavior to cope with stressors
using their behavior and so getting
animals what they need to use that
behavior to control their environment if
they want to is not just important for
their welfare but it's also an important
way of treating them like humans who
typically do have these opportunities
and so potentially this is also a way of
making results of animal research more
applicable to human patients so what
I've talked so far what I've talked
about so far is how we have as research
animals and how we can do that in a way
that treats them more like we treat
humans I've talked about how this might
impact the validity of preclinical
research now I'm going to turn to how we
treat animals in the moments when we're
running tests on them and by what I mean
by this is how to treat them outside of
the let's say 23 hours a day when
they're just sitting in their home cage
how do we treat them when we take them
out to actually run tests or to take
measurements I think it turns out
there's something fundamentally
different about the context in which we
usually test humans and the context in
which we usually test animals and what's
different is that humans participate in
studies voluntarily they sign
farm and they can choose not to
participate if they don't want to but
animals are coerced into taking part of
in studies and for a mouse when it's
time to run tests or to take
measurements what being coerced usually
means is being picked up by an
experimenter who by the way looks and
smells like a predator to them and then
being moved out of your home cage into
some sort of testing apparatus and these
are all things that we know are aversive
to mice and there's actually good
evidence that these aversive parts of
the procedure can have some pretty
dramatic impacts on the outcomes that we
measured here's some data from the
mobile lab at McGill University
they were found pain and nociception in
mice and one of the standard tests that
they use is the tail emergentist take a
mouse's tail and you this one reduces to
dip but you get them as a sail into hot
water and then you measure how long it
takes for the mouse to withdraw that
fail and what they did in this study was
that they pulled together data from over
8,000 mice that they had tested over
years and years to evaluate all the
potential factors that could affect how
quickly mice withdraw their tails and
they found that nearly half of the
variance in the appcode which is huge
could be explained by the environment of
the test the most important part of that
environment was the identity of the
tester the mice consistently take longer
to withdraw their tails from hot water
when they're tested by certain specific
human individuals in fact the identity
of the tester was the single most
predictive factor in determining that
outcome this is true even though all the
testers were working in the same lab
with the same equipment and with the
same protocol the most amazing part of
this is that the identity of the tester
actually had a larger effect than the
genotypes of the mice did I have to
understand in this line of research
that's usually what experimenters are
trying to determine do mice with
different genotypes have different
phenotypes do genetic differences
explain behavioral differences but what
these researchers shows that who test
the animals actually introduces a huge
amount of variation or noise into the
data that could potentially drown out
any of the
affects that they're looking for it
seems like there might be an obvious
solution to this if you're running this
lab you'll send standardized the test
will say let's have the same person test
all of the mice but the problem actually
runs deeper than that and that's because
individual testers don't have uniform
effects on all the mice the effects of
each tester actually depend on the
genotype of the mice
to put it differently the effect of the
mouse of genotype depends on who the
tester is and that's what's called a
genotype by environment interaction here
what we mean by environment is the
person was doing the testing and we can
see in this example here a genotype by
environment interaction if you look at
the person labeled SW the arthur sonia
wilson she tested hundreds of mice and
after doing this she found that deviate
to jameise the middle bar with two other
fields faster than AJ mice the rightmost
part but then that's also the person
labeled JMS Jeffery Mogul bled the head
of the lab and he also tested hundreds
of mice and he found no difference if
anything the difference may be reversed
and in later research the same lab
actually found that mice find the smell
of men more versus in the smell of women
and so being tested by a male
experimenter causes something called
stress induced analgesia which might be
part of the reason why Jeffrey's mice
leave their tails in the hot water
longer than Sonja's mice so this is a
pretty dramatic example where an
experiment actually gives you completely
different answers according to something
that seems so inconsequential is who the
person handling testing devices and
potentially how a versus if they find
being handled by that person here's one
more example of a genotype by
environment interaction in the mouse
testing these are the results of a
spatial memory test called the Barnes
maze if you're familiar with the Morris
water maze the Barnes maze is basically
the dry version of it so mice are placed
inside of a round area that has many
holes in the floor and their task is to
find
correct hole that gets them a reward and
after performing this test multiple
times they learn to navigate to the
correct hole more and more quickly and
these experimenters here ran two
different versions of the Barnes maze
the first one was negatively reinforced
there were fans blowing air inside the
arena during the test my spine is versat
their air even blowing over them and so
the reward was that when they found the
correct hole that hole that the mice
escaped from the testing arena and in
this test the researchers found very
clear differences between the strains
the DVA mice and white were much slower
to learn the task than c57 mice but the
second version of the test was identical
except that there weren't any fans low
near india and the test was positively
reinforced the reward for finding the
correct hole was food and in this case
there was absolutely no difference
between the strains they both learned
just as rapidly as the c57 s in the
first experiment so like in the mobile
experiment that I talked about before
this is a case where your conclusion
about which mice are in this case the
best spatial learners depends on how
aversive the testing environment is the
DBA mice in particular were negatively
impacted by aversive testing conditions
and that's actually an example of what's
known as the Yerkes dogs in law this is
a behavioral law that stems from
experiments done in the 1930s in these
experiments European dotson tested
rodents and how quickly they would learn
to perform a wide range of different
operative responses in order to avoid
getting electric shocks and what they
both found was that stronger shocks were
more motivating they made animals learn
more quickly which makes that but that
was true only up to a certain point in
the case of cognitive tasks that were
actually complex that were difficult to
learn performance actually started
degrading when shocks became too severe
and so that's shown by that rising and
falling curve at the bottom of that
graph and the general law that came out
of this work and that's actually been
observed on many occasions since then is
that for difficult cognitive tasks
performance is poor when arousal
is very low when motivation is low but
the front is also for when arousal
becomes too high because the individual
is then under some considerable stress
so we've seen in this section that the
stress associated with testing can alter
experimental results it can affect
something basic like how quickly your
reflexes kick in to make a mouse pull
their tails out of the water and it can
affect more complex outcomes like
performance on a difficult cognitive
task try to keep this in mind as I move
through the rest of the top because I'm
going to be focusing specifically now on
tests of learning and memory and because
I'll be talking about using automated
homepage versions of these tests and one
of the primary goals of this is to
reduce or to eliminate the aversive
context that's associated with the
conventional hand run test in other
words the goal or one of the goals of
these approaches is to give animals
control over testing and measurement so
that they engaged with the apparatus
voluntarily when they watch it just like
human subjects so to start this section
and what is it really about a standard
hand run operon test
that's so aversive to a mouse well first
there's being handled by a predator like
experimenter which we talked about a
little bit already second is the fact
that the arena or the chamber in which
the mouse is being tested can also be
reverse upon its own this can be true
even if there's not a fan blowing hair
in the barns of his experiment mice are
neo phobic by Nature which means that an
environment can be aversive to them just
because it's novel or unfamiliar and
getting over that can require some
pretty considerable work in terms of
habituating a mouse to a new environment
the third problem is that mice are often
socially separated from their companions
during a test and we saw earlier that
social support can be very important in
helping animals cope with other types of
stressors finally mice are often food
deprived before taking the test and
that's done to make sure that they're
actually motivated to work for food
during the test so if we consider these
different types of potential problems
with and run tests
we go about alleviating that making test
environments less aversive let's start
with handling it's starting to ask
whether it's even possible to handle
mice in a way that they don't find
aversive they might just be
intrinsically terrified of us well sure
the typical way to handle masses to pick
them out by the tail I read a few papers
where researchers tried to be treating
mice to this so that they'd find
handling less aversive by the time to
test it but these habituation procedures
usually take a very long time and they
have missed success
but Jane Hearst and her colleagues did
something different they exploited it
the fact that mice will instinctively
run into a shelter in the presence of a
perceived predator like a human so what
they do is they put a tunnel into the
mouse's home cage like a plexiglass tile
not natural cuphead and then the my
house will run straight into the tons of
high and then the experimenter can pick
up this tunnel and after a relatively
brief period of gradual training where
the tunnel was brought further and
further away from the homepage my Slough
voluntarily run into the tunnel when a
human comes into it to handle them an
imp reference desks mice have actually
shown that they prefer this mice we're
used to being handled in a tunnel will
voluntarily interact with the humans
hand and they'll interact with the
tunnel mice were used to being handled
by the tail we'll avoid that the
appellant handled mice even allowed
humans to scratch them like this and
they continued to volunteer to be
handled even after this happens mice can
also be trained to jump or walk onto a
cut hand of the experimenter and then be
carried while standing on the hand and
they'll also voluntarily interact with
the experimenters hand while they'll
handle mice will not notice again that
this is an issue of whether or not the
mice have control over stressors in the
environment being grabbed by the tail is
something that's outside of their
control but if the experimenter is
instead asking them to walk into a
tunnel or jump onto their hand when
they're ready that really does put them
in control of what might otherwise be a
much more immersive experience
Anderson company actually showed that
these handling techniques can affect the
quality of data here's an odor
recognition test that they performed
mice handled in different ways what
happens in this test is that a mouse is
put into a box that contains a cotton
pad which has urine from a male maps on
it they then measure how long the female
spends sniffing this urine when they
repeat assess over three days with the
same males urine what they expect to see
is what you see in the habituation part
of this graph the light blue that she
recognizes and remembers this particular
smell and so she spends less and less
time sniffing it from day to day then on
the very last day this cotton pad is
replaced with one that contains urine
from a different male so what happened
then what we expect to see is that the
female disobey sheets and she starts
sleeping the cotton pad again and this
shows that she knows that the two urines
are different and that's exactly what
they found in mice or handle using a
tunnel in the non aversive way but in
mice or handled by the tail which
remember is the standard method of doing
this we don't see habituation and we
don't see this situation and it looks
like that graph is empty but that's
actually what it should look like
because what the graph shows is the
median response for each trial in the
odor recognition test and for every
trial that median responds with zero
second spent sniffing the cotton pad
which means that tail handling had such
a large inhibitory effect on exploration
of that apparatus that most of the mice
just never engage with the test stimulus
at all in case that's not obvious that
kind of ruins this test so handed mice
using a tunnel is one way that we can
make measurements less aversive and
potentially improve the quality of these
measures but if the animals are picked
up using a tunnel just so that they can
be transferred into an operant chamber
the other problems remain they might
still be socially isolated they might be
so tested in a strange environment so
the other solution which also avoids
aversive handling is to test my strictly
in their home page and that
simultaneously tackles some of these
other problems as it turns out that also
solves the food deprivation problem
animals don't have to be food deprived
to maintain motivation because they
actually decide for themselves when
they'll engage with the test in their
home cage generally they want
if they're not hungry and motivated for
the reward but let's really take a look
at why motivation can be less than
optimal and standard hand run tests
first of all mice have a nocturnal or a
group us killer feeding pattern most of
their eating of food and cake is done in
the early part of the night this can be
a problem because the typical working
pattern of a scientist is diurnal their
work in the lab tends to be done during
the day when mice are usually sleepy and
not so hungry so every scientist wants
to be in the lab testing mice from 9:00
to 5:00 they've already got a potential
motivation problem on their hands of
course it's a solvable problem
because maybe you have a scientist who's
a night owl or maybe you're keeping your
mice on the reverse light cycle which
means that their day becomes our night
and in these cases then the scientists
working hours and the Mouse's working
hours coincide but even in this case you
can't get around the fact that mice have
tiny little stalks they get stay she is
very quickly I might as well eat
something like four grams of food per
day but if it's up to them they'll
spread that out over several hours and
they usually won't eat much more than
about half a gram at any given time
there within any short period of time so
this means that even though as a
scientist you'd like ideally to be able
to run 100 trials of an operon test in
each individual section the mouse simply
isn't interested in working for food for
that long and here's what that can look
like when an animal is not interested in
working for food in our eyes
hmm it appears that the video is not
showing up technical difficulties
let me take a second in case the video
issue doesn't resolve I will describe
what we're seeing we see the mass so the
videos will not play so we've got a
mouse inside of the teammate a standard
hand run teammates one that I Mouse will
be carried into and then tested and his
teammates has a left arm and a right arm
that contained bowls of food but we see
at the beginning of the clip is the
mouse on task solved in the Bravo the
mouse walks right to the back of the TR
into the right arm and fetches food from
one of the bowls correct answered great
but in the second part of the clip we
see her now start wandering around a
prize she wanders over to the other who
puts her paws up on it doesn't even look
inside she goes back to the start of the
apparatus then goes back into the right
choice arm and she's rearing up a lot on
the sides of the apparatus she's not
even looking for food so it seems that
she's exploring the apparatus at this
point for an entirely different purpose
and the danger is that if were not
attentive to this then when we see a
mouse wandering into one of the choice
arms and maybe she's just exploring
maybe she's not trying to solve our
clever puzzle that we've set up forward
we can mistake that for a mouse who is
actually trying to solve the puzzle and
if she gets the wrong answer then we
might be led to think that it's because
she has for learning or for memory
capacity when in fact committee is just
that motivation is lacking at this
particular moment
so as I've mentioned before a potential
solution to this is to let animals work
only when they're motivated to work once
again this is obviously a recurring
theme what you're doing here is giving
animal control if the test apparatus is
part the animals home cage or if it's
attached to the animal's home cage that
means that are free to go in and to be
when they're motivated to do so and for
MS this will usually mean at night and
in short bursts I think back again to
that yerkes-dodson law we're avoiding
the rightmost side of that solid line
there the side where the stress of
handling and of aversive testing becomes
too great and start to be started 2d
created for products overall so avoiding
the zone of low arousal on the left side
because that can also lead to low
performance we're doing that by not
testing animals when we've just opened
them up in the middle of the day or when
there are otherwise in a period of low
activity we're letting them decide to
take the test only when they're hungry
and when they're ready to do so when
they're moderately aroused somewhere
you're the center of that graph where
they may be able to perform at a peak
level and I have a video that I would
like to show you that shows what that
looks like what testing an animal in an
automated teammate as we see pictured
there can look like and what you see at
first is the animal standing in the main
chamber
what's late what's a labeled s test side
here and the animals walking around
doing basically the same thing that we
saw in the first video which is off-task
behavior walking around smelling things
exploring then she goes into the start
arm of the teammates and actually gives
a response what's great about this is
that in this context it's entirely fine
that she's performing on task behavior
because that off-task behavior takes
place in the whole cage itself and it
doesn't take place in the maze that's
attached to the homepage so that means
as much less danger the onus take off
task behavior for on task behavior and
end up with basically John data we won't
mistake a mouse who's exploring the
apparatus for one who's actually trying
to solve the puzzle and get a reward now
there's some interesting results from a
study that used an automated apparatus
the same one in that diagram there the
automated team is to study the effects
of motivation and satiation on
performance in a spatial discrimination
fast this was done by briana Gaskill and
she trained two mice in this apparatus
using three different reward sizes
either one two
for pellets and what she found was that
maestro better overall performance in
the long run if she trained them using
small rather than large rewards and
that's exactly what she predicted
because mice become stationed very
rapidly if they're given large pieces of
food for each correct response and then
they lose motivation to answer correctly
on the next trial she also found that
performance was much less variable with
small rewards the mice who were trained
the small rewards got very good overall
scores in every successive block of ten
trials that they performed but for the
mice trained with larger rewards there
were some blocks of ten trials where
they were really on task and they had
excellent scores and there were other
blocks of ten trials where they seemed
to be totally off and the performance
was terrible and that's assists a
symptom of that fluctuating motivation
of working really hard when you're
hungry and then not really so hard
hungry actually found something pretty
similar in some of my own work so over
the past few years I've been working on
building and automated home cage
apparatus to regulate and to monitor
access to drinking water we build these
drink of units and installed it in the
walls of Mouse home cages and the
drinkers are equipped with RFID readers
that detect and identify individual mice
when they stick their heads in to lift
the spout and that's monitored and it's
logged by a computer program that then
triggers a pump to push out some water
to the mouse when the mouse comes to
make the drinkers also have LEDs and
different colors built into them you can
see a blue and a green one here and we
can use these for learning experiments
we can use the lights to hue the mice to
tell them when water is available or
where water is available and when it's
not so I did an experiment right cranked
mice to perform a visual discrimination
they had two drinkers in their own cage
there were three mice in the cage
and each Mouse was assigned a different
color of led here for example one Mouse
is assigned to the green light that's at
the top left of every drinker in the
cage and another is assigned to the blue
light at the bottom left of every drink
cage and so on and at any given time
each Mouse had a light on at 1 drinker
but not at the other drinker and they
need
to go to the drinker with the light on
to get water I was able to get mice to
perform this task quite well by training
them in three stages of increasing
difficulty so that by the last stage
they were able to go to the correct
drinker
I think attention to their specific
light light at the right color while
ignoring the lights of the other colors
that were assigned to their cage means
and since the mice approach the drinkers
at irregular intervals whenever they
choose in this kind of voluntary setup I
was able to use the use data from this
experiment to show that one of the main
determinants of how likely a mouse was
to choose the correct drinker the one
with the light on was how thirsty that
mouse was how long has it been since
this mouse has last had a dream if an
acid last had a drink in the last minute
then that mask performed at basically
chance leveled 50:50 giving it right or
getting it wrong but the longer it had
been since she'd had a drink the better
that mouse performance was again
presumably because the more thirsty you
are the higher is your motivation to get
the right answer okay so to do a little
brief recap we're using automated phone
cage offering tasks because we want to
make testing less aversive and because
we want to maintain motivation and we've
already seen some data that shows that
each of these components making less
immersive meeting motivation can improve
performance on cognitive tasks in
isolation but does the automated testing
itself work does it improve cognitive
performance well the answer does seem to
be yes here's a comparison of overall
performance by my mice in a team aids
alternation test so this is a task where
the mice are rewarded for giving the
opposite of whatever their last response
was and this was run in a standard hand
run version and an automated homepage
version the same one that you've seen
diagrams out before it turned out the
mice tested in the automated cage
perform significantly better than mice
tested in the standard way and the
automated maze helped either by
maintaining motivation or by reducing
however syphilis
there may be some above and again we
might see this as an animal who has
control over their testing schedule and
the animals choosing to work when
they're at that optimal level of
moderate arousal a sleepy in a nine in
distress and so I mean a testing and
boost performance but there's a
potentially more important set of
questions does automated testing make
the data better or higher quality is it
more consistent does it more accurately
measure what we think it measures or
what we hope it matters is it more
relevant to the human patients that the
animals are being used as models up I
think some of these questions especially
towards the end we don't quite have
answers to yet but here are some things
that we do know this is a table that
shows the main results from a big study
in international multi laboratory study
where a group of collaborators asked
whether they could replicate the same
results in different labs and they were
specifically looking for differences
between mice of different genetic
strains and have a five test that they
performed they found genotype by
environment interactions and four of
these tests these are shown by the red
box here remember what the genotype by
environment interaction means is that
for these four tests different labs gave
different answers some labs found
differences between genetic strengths
that other labs did not interestingly
there was one test that didn't show a
genotype by environment interaction one
test where everyone got the same man and
that was preference for drinking and all
that also happens to be the only test in
this entire paper that's run in the home
gauge all of the other tests were tested
the experimenters handled the mice and
placed them in some sort of apparatus
there was actually a similar multi lab
study that was run later on using only
automated homepage tests beams and
apparatus called the intellij j-- and
they found consistent results the same
strain differences in all the labs on
all of their outcome measures and these
authors pointed specifically to not
handling the animals as one of the
factors that was likely responsible for
this now as to the question of whether
automated tests are not just more
but more accurately measure what we want
them to measure I do wonder whether some
of the strain differences in learning or
in memory that are reported in the
literature might sometimes actually the
artifacts of other kinds of strain
differences here's what I mean for
example let's say one string
consistently does better than another
genetic strain on a hand Rivest of
memory is it because that first test
truly has a better memory or is it maybe
for example because that strain is less
fearful and so is less impacted by
inversive test environment um this is
something that I actually like to test
in the near future I'd like to do is to
choose a type of test and a group of
strains of mice or the literature says
we should expect some pretty clear
strain differences and ideally this
would be a group of strength that's also
known to differ in how they react to
aversive hanwen novel environment and
then I'd like to run these animals
through a hand run and automated
versions of the exact same tests which I
don't think anyone has done in a multi
screen study yet what I predict is that
the hand run tests will reveal some
strain differences for example in this
mock-up graph the different that strain
a outperform strain B but I also pretty
good these differences might not be
present in the automated test and that
would actually provide some some I think
compelling and direct evidence that it's
specifically the way that the test is
run that is creating these strain
differences and in the longer term I
think a potential extent extension of
this project would be to run it again as
a multi lab study and directly compare
automated and Android versions of the
exact same tests to see whether the
automated version is again more easily
replicated now with the brief time that
I have left I have to show you that
using an operant apparatus inside of a
mice of a message home cage has other
applications than just scientific data
collection you could also use it for
some veterinary applications like
routine health monitoring so here's an
example from a lab a banana at us that
we nicknamed mouse monitor there's a
plexiglass tube that's attached to a
hole in the wall of this
escaped when mice enter the tube they're
detected and they're identified by an
rfid reader that then triggers release
of a food pellet so going into the tube
is how they forage and the tube is
mounted on a scale so besides hitting
foraging data from the mice a couple
hundred times a date whenever they go
onto the tube we also get dozens and
dozens of different bodyweight readings
for each mouse on each day and that lets
us see some pretty subtle effects like
the fight like the fact that mice
actually gradually change in body weight
throughout the day they lose up to about
a gram during daylight hours while
they're mostly sleeping the idea behind
using this apparatus for this project
was to test it out as a way of
monitoring a routine health monitoring
in animals away if identifying sick
animals early one other thing that
motivates this project is that there was
an epidemiological study published a few
years ago that looked at all the
morbidities reported in a large Mouse
research facility and out of all the
morbidities that happen the most common
one was caretakers just finding a mouse
dead before they ever knew that anything
was wrong with the maps finding mice
dead was more common than finding the
other most common problems like
ulcerative dermatitis or fight wounds
and so if we can make an automated
surveillance system that can flag
animals when they fall sake before it's
too late
then that could help a lot in the future
in terms of either getting animals
treated or humanely euthanized before
they spontaneously die and it turns out
that this apparatus can detect illness
in mice well before a human observer can
some of the mice in our project got an
injection of LPS which induces sickness
behavior and the difference between
these mice and the control mice who were
not sit could be detected behaviorally
by this apparatus within two to four
hours after the injection and it
manifested in the form of reduced
feeding behavior now in contrast to this
human caretakers who were physically
examining the mice could not tell the
difference between the sick and the
healthy mice on the morning after the
injection nor on the afternoon after the
injection
four hours later and so that's an
example of how capping into foraging
motivation of lab animals using this
sort of homepage foraging apparatus can
let us collect some essential data on
their health or other purposes and
research to finish I'd like to touch on
one more thing I focused so far in this
talk mainly on how taking the average
apparatus and bringing it into the
homepage let's just get rid of all the
aversive aspects of a hammer-on test the
thing that might don't like about them
but I think we can go further than that
if we designed the tasks right we can
make it so that my stone just not this
like room we can make it so that the
might actually like the tasks which
means that we'd be taking what's
normally a bad testing experience and
turning it into something that animals
actually want to do and we do this by
turning it into something that we have
control over and that's a form of
enrichment that we would add to their
home environments now how do we know
whether experimental animals really like
a task how do we know that they're doing
it because they like it and not just
because that's how we've said I've
inspired their environment because we
basically bribe them bite on them you
have to do this to get food every day
well here's a nice example from the
literature right that gets pretty clear
that the animals like the past there's a
video that goes with this and I really I
encourage you to look up this this paper
and look at the videos in the
supplementary materials because they're
really worth a look this is work by Gigi
mbatha-raw
who trained dozens of individual wild
birds on a visual discrimination task
rather she put the apparatus in the
forest and the birds just started coming
to it I volunteered to train themselves
and the video in question is when the
bird was clearly mastered picking on
whichever key on this apparatus displays
a red light in exchange for some of you
learnt and sympathies are wild animals
who are engaged with an opport apparatus
in their native environment I think it's
definitely clear that it's not the case
that they're somehow forced into into
performing this task because there are
other places they can get food and they
you don't even have to come near this
box if they're not interested
and there's another phenomenon that
suggests that captive animals also like
to work
it's called contra freeloading and it's
been observed repeatedly in many
different species contrary contra
freeloading is when animals prefer to
work to get food instead of getting that
same food for free for example you might
have a bowl of free food beside a leaper
in Afghan we'll pull that lever that
dispenses the same food that is
available in the bowl right beside it
and animals will pull that leaper an
example of this that I really like is
one that comes from Biggs
so things in this study were exposed to
two types of pen one where it was easy
to get food and one where it was
difficult to get food
the first then had straw on the floor
and food in a trough very easy to get
the second one also had strong floor and
had the same type of food but it was
scattered inside the straw which meant
the food was harder to get because the
pigs had to route through the straw with
their noses to find it and when they
were later tested as to which
environment they prefer to spend time in
the pigs actually chose the environment
where they had to work for food to find
that food in the straw the reason that I
like this specific experiment is because
it's one or the tasks of the pigs have
to perform to get that food is a normal
part of their repetitive behavior as
paid pigs are intrinsically motivated to
root in the substrate or food when
they're hungry so it makes a lot of
sense that a pig would like this type of
work and it illustrates how using what
the animal is naturally designed to do
is a huge part of making a successful
enrichment making a successful operative
task in addition to tapping into the
animals natural foraging repertoire I
think something else we should consider
when designing operative cognitive cat
tasks in the home cage is whether these
tasks are cognitively stimulating to the
animals because I could make them extra
enriching there's an interesting review
paper on this topic on how we can make
cognitive tasks interesting to animals
and in this paper the author's proposed
that a crucial dimension that determines
how an animal feels about it
is how challenging that task is and
whether or not the degree of challenge
is well matched to the animals degree of
skill if that is too easy the animals
may become bored with it if it's too
difficult and it become frustrated but
if a task is well matched the level of
skill then the authors suggest that if
these animals are anything like humans
they might experience what in psychology
is called a state of slow flow is this
rewarding highly engaged state of mind
that I think globally we could call
being in the zone and I think I
experience flow sometimes as an example
when I'm writing computer code or when
I'm climbing at the climbing wall and in
both cases it happens when that level
challenge is just right when I'm just
about got it and I really need to just
give the task my full attention and
effort to succeed the outside the world
kind of loses focus and fades away
because I'm fully concentrated and
that's a really rewarding federal state
and to give it's something that we can
possibly let animals experience when
they're in our care then that would be a
great target to strive for and that
might mean making operative tasks in the
home gauge progressively more difficult
as the animals gain and competence to
keep that match between competence and
skill and that is a good fit with how
some complex tasks have to be thought
any way they have to be taught in stages
and so I think that by keeping these
design principles in mind we can come up
with the right tasks that animals will
end up enjoying in the bill want to
engage with so to summarize I hope I've
shown you that there's potential in
designing automated versions of tests
for laboratory animals and integrating
these tests into their home environments
that there's potential to make the lives
of Daniels better by giving them back
some measure of control giving them the
option to avoid aversive situations the
option to participate in our experiments
only when they want to and even the
options to seek out intense positive
experience experiences but actually
that's where the true environmental
enrichment is and there's potential in
doing this to improve the quality of
assignments as well potential to get
more consistent results
that can be replicated between labs and
hopefully to get more meaningful results
because we start treating animals like
we treat human patients which means
giving them control and placing priority
on their well-being and I think I hope
that in the long run this can lead to
improved welfare for the live animals
and to improved outcomes for human
patients so to finish I would like to
thank all of my collaborators listed
here who worked with me on the projects
that I've mentioned in a stop thanks to
the lab roots for giving me the
opportunity to speak today and thanks to
Alexis for moderating and thanks to
everyone for watching thank you I would
like to once again thank Jamie for that
informative presentation we'll now start
the live Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left your presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is why are some of the tools
that are available to someone who wants
to start using automated tests like this
and where do you start okay um I think
there are maybe two routes that you can
go and maybe depends how how comfortable
you are tinkering so one wrap that you
can go is the sort of commercial
commercially available the route of use
and commercially available equipment
so the entelechy time ention during this
presentation is I think the biggest
player in terms of being a ready-made
solution that you can buy and start
using in your lab and when the
intellikeys a cage that's outfitted with
the offered corners which are sides of
the cage that the animals can go to and
be are identified the RFID and perform
an operant ask with light cubes much
like in the apparatus that I showed you
that I'm designed with
water rewards and so on and there are
some other players in the market
I can't list all of them off the top of
my head but some of the others that are
there are actually derivatives of the
Intel acade so there's the steno queue I
believe which is based on the Intel
occasion is really targeted at
researchers and drug discovery might be
something to look at if you're that area
and there's the steno master which is a
modular version of the intelligence so
instead of being a full-on cage that
comes with everything it's for example
the offered corners a standalone that
you could pump into another cage the
other rocky crypto if you're interested
in tinkering is reading academic papers
by teams like ours and many others who
are building these environments and then
releasing a lot of the details for
example for our water drinker apparatus
we'll be releasing a lot of that open
source in the near future and a lot of
these environments are based on RFID
they're using RFID to track position or
using RFID to identify individual
animals within group settings and
usually these are either built directly
into the cages or they're built into
larger environments kind of a imagine
free-range mice living 40 to a bar there
are some papers like this and sometimes
they're built into attachments that are
added on to a cage like a maze that sits
outside of the cage and lets animals
enter and perform a task and last thing
I mention is there's actually a lot of
academic teams as well as some
commercial teams using machine vision
and this is kind of a different approach
this is collecting data in the homepage
but it's usually doing so in I guess you
could call it a passive way so animals
being filmed and some sort of parameters
about position location and potentially
behaviors like grooming or social
behavior or vital signs are being
extracted
there's actually a talk in our track in
this lab roots conference on this kind
of approach and that is in Edison
contrast to the approach that I've been
talking about which is active data
collection because you get data when the
animal interacts with the apparatus
rather than just by filming the animal
but I think it could be interesting to
see whether these start to emerge in the
future as far as I know it hasn't but
there are some of the machine and vision
approaches that try to identify animals
visually and I could see that
potentially being combined if it's done
in real time with some of these active
approaches with almost always rely on
RFID and if that was the case this
animal could just be identified visually
in real time we could skip the whole
RFID implantation procedure and that
would make it even less invasive it's
already fairly minimally invasive thanks
for the question our next question is
you mentioned several cases where
different researchers or different labs
do the same experiment that get
different results how would we go about
testing excuse me how would we go about
telling which one of them got the right
answer okay let me answer that in two
parts
so I think the first part is that if two
let's get different results neither one
of them is necessarily right because of
what's known as phenotypic plasticity
which is basically that a genotype
doesn't always result in the same
phenotype the same beaver lab but for
example a certain genotype or the
phenotype is the product of the genotype
and environment the environment includes
things like the lab where the experiment
is conducted and so because of that is
kind of normal that sometimes we get
different answers in different
environments and it's not because
anybody because one lab is right in this
one's wrong or one that's screwed up or
something
there are paper just very good papers on
this by handle verbal if you're
interested in the issue and and this
kind of approach where we kind of
embrace the diversity of different
outcomes of different populations and
fits with the idea of personalized
medicine in humans where different
treatments work for different people or
in different environments and sometimes
they don't work for others in other
environments or in other people with
different genetics for example and so I
think that by running the studies in
many environments
so finding out that works here but not
there if we do this enough maybe we can
start to understand why it is that it
works here not there and maybe what the
relevant differences are the second part
of my answer is that I do think that
sometimes some testing environments are
more right than others specifically when
we're doing something to make them more
human-like better models of the actual
population and that's mostly what I've
been talking about today an example it
is striking but I didn't mention in this
top is a paper published in 2016 where
they look at the immune systems of mice
in specific pathogen free barrier
facilities so these are facilities where
you come in and you've gone up and you
get an air shower and germs do not make
it into this facility that extremely
clean and sterile and go to the immune
systems of these mice and compare them
to mice from a pet store or mice who
live in a barn and when they found that
actually in some respects the immune
systems of the mice in the SPS facility
are kind of like the immune system of a
newborn human and the immune systems of
the the dirty mice from the pet store
are more like an adult humans immune
system and so if you think about a case
like that I think if we're trying to use
models that are meant to represent adult
humans with normally functioning immune
systems then it might be more right to
do the experiment in mice who have
normal immune systems because they live
in somewhat dirty environments which of
course doesn't mean that we should never
work on mice with immune systems that
are no good or work on mice who are
socially isolated because of course
there are people who are
immunocompromised and there are people
who are socially isolated and of course
it's worth developing treatments for
them too it's just important to be
conscious of who it is that you're
modeling when you work with these
different Mouse populations or in
different studies thank you
our next question is how much our
automated test being used right now in
preclinical research are they pretty
common at this point I think that
depends somewhat on the specific area
that you're looking at so I think
there's definitely been a big push in a
lot of these
a lot of preclinical research to
automate the procedures to automate the
testing procedures and that's important
the desire to do high throughput
genotyping to do everything very
efficiently and of course things
efficiently a lot of the time means
taking the human labor out of it um but
a lot of the time that still means
developing and operated at Rattus that
is a standalone thing that mice will be
carried to and put into which of course
then is not at all the same thing as
this automated homepage test day because
they're still handling they're still
actually this unfamiliar box so I've
seen a lot less of the actual homepage
automation like I've been talking today
one area where I have seen a good
benefit is in neurodegenerative model
neurodegenerative disease models and
that might be partially because the
symptoms that are interest in these
kinds of diseases are partially
cognitive and if you look up for example
papers on Huntington's disease there's
several interesting papers showing that
automated cognitive testing in the home
page is a good way of early detecting
symptoms of Huntington's quite early in
mouse models so that's that's the main
area that I know that I see news how
much are automated tests being used
right now in preclinical research are
they pretty common at this point um I
think in a lot of areas of preclinical
research there's it's definitely been a
push towards trying to use automated
environments to make the research right
throughput in other words to take the
people out of it in a lot of cases to
make the research more efficient to be
able to test for mice and Monday for
example and so that means automating a
lot of the apparatus although in a lot
of these cases that means creating an
operand apparatus that sits by itself in
testing room and then carrying mice over
to the F rats and putting them inside so
even the less kind of widespread form of
automation it's very different from this
home page automation has different goals
one area of free clinic
research where I have seen a fair bit of
automation in the homepage an automatic
data collection in the home page is
models of neurodegenerative disease and
I think that's partially because the the
symptoms that are of interest in
neurodegenerative neurodegenerative
disease are often cognitive symptoms
aren't a memory and if you look up
Huntington's disease models in
particular there are several good papers
where the researchers show that this
kind of monitoring actually leads to
early detection of Huntington's disease
symptoms our next question is how far do
you think that this we go are there
other types of tests that could be
automated and run in the home plate and
are there some types of tests that this
just wouldn't work for I think that
there are definitely other tests that
this approach could spread to so I've
been mainly talking here about operand
tests that are marking a cognitive in
nature asking an animal to come solve
some sort of puzzle to to get a reward
but potentially you can do this for any
kind of behavior that you could bribe
the animal into performing really so I
could picture some some kinds of common
tests like maybe a rotor a test or grip
strength test method right now is
usually done automatically being done
like this perhaps in some sort of little
module that would be attached to a cage
temporarily for the duration of the test
I could also see larger kind of maze
tests like an elevated plus maze or an
open field being used with these kinds
of approaches as well by maybe having a
port in the side of a cage and then
wheeling one of these mazes over and
attaching it to the port no they might
come through and test themselves and
explore these arenas when they're ready
with something like an open field that's
really what the test is about is the
mouse going to explore the arena there
there are some other types of tests that
I don't see working in a sense
environmentally for example if you've
got a test that is about the animals
reaction to aversive
and Ling or to some other aversive
treatment and of course it might be it
would be counterproductive to take that
aversive component out like for example
the restraint stress test that I showed
with the hamsters and rats early on in
the top you don't want to take the
restraints out of there because then you
have no more tests and I think there's
obviously some veterinary applications
where even if we're doing this kind of
monitoring like I talked about in Mouse
monitor and being able to flag sick
animals early on we're not going to take
all the hands off out of that because
got a sick animal maybe the vet needs to
palpate it or pick it up to really
examine properly yeah so I think makes
the magic answer and it looks like like
it looks like we have time for one more
question you talked about how animals
wouldn't volunteer to get tested when
they're not motivated but then you also
showed that the animals in automated
tests do make responses when they're not
hungry or when they're not thirsty
so does this really solve that problem
of localization if they're still making
responses then yeah so you're right that
in the in the foraging experiment on
smaller large rewards I showed decreased
performance in animals were trained with
larger words and attributed that to then
become associated and then especially in
my experiment on drinking in the mice I
show that they perform very badly when
they just had a drink so they're not
thirsty so it is in a way weird that
they're even deciding to go to the
apparatus and make a response when
they're not thirsty so first this isn't
perfect at only picking out the very
peak motivation moments of the animals
and it might be that these animals are
making responses where there are still
maybe a little bit little bit to drink
for just not very much we don't care
that much or it might be that they're
actually exploring at that point and not
trying to make a response that might be
difficult to distinguish but I think at
least the advantage that this gives is
if you think about that that water
reward visual discriminating again where
we looked at how long since the last
print one thing that this lets you do is
to examine the factors that determine
performance like how long it's been
since a mouse last strand and then go on
when the mouse hasn't had a drink when
the mouse has had a drink within the
last minute this data is basically
garbage and then I didn't go in there
and weed out that data and only keep the
data where the animals are at the
motivation so the animals can help us
along by picking their most motivated
type coins and we can do a bit of the
rest basically I would like to once
again thank Jamie for his presentation
I'd also like to thank lab rats for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I'd like to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you will receive an
email from laborat letting you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye goodbye thanks again Alexis and
right on